hard to believe this is the bed of one
of the largest reservoirs in southern
spain this jetty was floating and the
pedal boats were being used right at
this spot less than a year ago
but now parts of the venue reservoir are
bone dry and getting drier and it's
operating at only around 12 percent of
its capacity
look at the state of this earth the
cracks are so deep the levels are
dropping at a terrifying rate all of
this was once under water and the
environmentalists say it's not just
climate change that's a problem it's
water mismanagement and farmers
switching to crops which demand much
more water
whatever the reason the record high
temperatures have led to fractured
relations here and what's being dubbed
the water wars as farmers and
environmentalists squabble over who and
what's caused this
these are some of the exotic fruits
being blamed for the water drain
many farmers like paco have branched out
into growing mangoes and avocados
he's telling us here how efficient his
irrigation system is but the drought has
meant his mangoes are still
significantly smaller and his income has
dropped nearly a quarter over the past
few years
the lack of water fires everything it's
all down to climate change and we're all
causing climate change so we have to
change
he's built his own reservoir and is
investigating growing less thirsty
fruits like barbary figs but all the
farms around here are suffering under
these extreme conditions
ecologists in the area say poor farming
and lack of planning by the authorities
are responsible
there's already a problem because too
many farmers are using irrigation and we
have to stop that and persuade them to
find alternatives like recycling water
and growing other fruits
the hot dry weather is due to continue
until the autumn
with farms working all hours to try to
save their crops
maroon boys show just how tourism is
already suffering around the reservoir
elena sanchez was left with no option
but to close down her water adventure
business
and there was water here yes
and she's worried if farming of tropical
fruits like avocados and mangoes
collapses it'll have a devastating
impact
the tropical industry it brings about 10
000 employments to this area so what are
these people going to work in if we
don't have tropicals
spain produces the bulk of europe's
fruit and vegetables this country's
water crisis is going to reach far
beyond its own borders